alles in Ordnung gute Weiterfahrt danke
[Musik]
schön Polizeihauptmeister müllb mein
Name
Verkehrskontrolle bitte ich bin no
gerade hinten ja das war die Allgemeine
Deutsche Verkehrskontrolle wir hier sind
bei der allgemeinen bayerischen
Verkehrskontrolle aha die bayerische
Verkehrskontrolle ja sie fahren hier auf
bayernstraßen D müssen wir schauen ob
sie dafür geeignet sind bitte mal
aussteigen ja
gerne
so so gut D fangen wir mal haen sie mich
einm an ich ich habe keinen Alkohol
getrunken ja keinen Tropfen nein ich
trinke tagsüber überhaupt kein Alkohol
ja das geht schon gut wieso ja weil in
Bayern ke Mensch do nüchtern durch die
gegenfah das gibt bei uns gar nicht ach
das habe ich nicht gewusst ja
Unwissenheit schützt aber vor Strafe
nicht du Glück dass ein guten Tag bei
mirwischt hab da W wir noch einmal ein
Auge
zudrücken so da trink mal im Ernst nein
im Spaß ja natürlich im Ernst oder w sie
ein Führerschein gleich abgeben stop
stop stop stop stopop stop schon wieder
durchgefallen nur ein Schwein trinkt
allein keine Manieren diese
Preise so PR die bin der Josef
[Applaus]
Michael so dann kommen wir zum
kulinarischen Teil der Prüfung wie heißt
es so schön in einem gesunden Körper
wohnt gesunder Geist gesunden Körper
kriegt man natürlich durchs Weißwurst
zsel so jetzt schau mal hier schö
Weißwurst ich bin Vegetarier das gibt's
ja nicht ja ich ja auch ich kann Rot und
Grün nicht
auseinanderhten
so das ist das ist ja furchtbar das gibt
punkteauzug das ist ja das ist ja
überhaupt nicht also wirklich na so wir
kommen zum nächsten Teil der Prüfung
eine ordentliche Prise königlich
bayerischer schnupftab ne nee bitte
nicht du kannst mal dem Führerschein
gleich
geben so da zum
Nachspülen
so und dann sind wir auch schon beim
letzten Teil der Übung angelangt und der
wäre ein zünftiger Erzherzog Johann
Jodler aus tiefster Brust das kann ich
nicht kommich fr
kanst unglaublich m du hast das
geschafft ich erteile dir hiermit die
bayerische verkehrseignung ab sofort
darfst du auf bayischen Straßen fahren
das muss gefeiert
werden so jetzt sch jetzt wünsche ich
dir eine gute Fahrt und schö Feiertag
okay ja schöne Feier
nachriving
home
Dings
[Applaus]
ja da haben wir über die Feiertage
Bayern Straßen wieder bisschen sicherer
[Applaus]
[Musik]
gemacht